just because you're determined doesn't
mean everything's going to go well
those four people that passed away were
they climbing with you
on fair grills and i've learned how to
survive on some of the most hostile
terrains on the planet you really
fascinate me for a number of reasons
that i actually never knew before i
started digging into your story you
certainly had a lot of demons
in the early days of tv especially there
was so much pressure to go and do that
and do the extra episode you end up
burning the things the most valuable
to be successful you have to sacrifice
but maybe you reach my way enough enough
selection for the special forces is all
about heart and spirit and we can all
have that that's not a god-given talent
that's a muscle that builds with walking
through the door of failure time and
time again and keep getting back up
when was your darkest moment
one was on when i broke my back and was
in rehabilitation for a long time and
you know so much of my rock in my life
had been that i was physically strong
and i was doing a job i loved and
suddenly i couldn't even reach the
bathroom without excruciating agony and
it was just what am i going to do with
my life when is there a time to give up
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diary of a ceo i hope nobody's listening
but if you are then please keep this to
yourself
[Music]
bear
i want to start where i usually start
which is
near the start and one of the things you
said was you certainly had a lot of
demons the quote the exact quote is i
was never short of demons when i read
that
i thought what do you what do you mean
growing up i really struggled with
confidence
you know definitely when i was at school
and i think uh you know i think so much
of the school culture still to this day
you know it definitely tends to
celebrate the
you know the guy who's academic or
sporty or good looking or just a cool
guy you know and that those are the
currency
of school
but as you and me know it's not always
the currency of life and you try and
tell a kid who
who maybe isn't sporty or academic who's
just kind and and
does his best
you know that actually those things have
much more value in life and it's kind of
hard to believe but certainly for me i
didn't i didn't have i wasn't the sport
you're the most academic or the cool guy
um
and i think it took me a while to
find an identity and actually this is
what
you know it's what i love and it's
nothing kind of
brilliant but but i love it and for me
growing up it was always climbing with
my dad you know he'd been a he'd been a
commando and and
loved all of that sort of stuff and for
me growing up it was always you know
that's what i love to do just just
have mini adventures with him and
i think it took a while to
learn that that's okay you know my dad
was always saying you gotta
find something you really love and try
and be kind to people along the way and
be resilient you know have that dog and
never give up attitude and that that's
that's the key things for life
and uh but it's hard to believe that as
a kid and sometimes if you get a bit
lost in the system
um so i suppose what i meant is that
it took me a while to find the
confidence you know and it's still a
journey i think we're all on you know i
think success doesn't always answer
those sort of questions and i think
confidence has to come from
in here
and it's often the opposite of what we
think it is when we're growing up you
know confidence is quiet and i think
that's where that's kind of what i meant
when you say confidence
what how do you define confidence
because some people think of confidence
as this like overt external expression
of like
self-assurance what did you mean when
you said i didn't have confidence and
it's still an ongoing battle what is
that i think it's not what the world
always thinks like you say you know we
always have this thing of confidence as
you say it's this unstoppable i can do
anything you know i think um life is
always humbling you know in every way
just like the wild you know the
mountains are humbling you know
the the real things of life humbling she
reminds us that
you know it's often a battle and you
know you've got to sometimes put your
head down and do your best and you're
going to fail and you're going to
struggle you're going to have doubts and
you're going to have self-doubt and but
but try try and get your feet keep going
and uh
and i think that is um
that is confidence you know confidence
is the quiet stuff and the and the
honesty and to to say this is a struggle
but
but let's go you know let's let's let's
do our best i love that thing of the
scouts you know do your best you know
which is so smart because i think so
much of the world is about be the best
you know win
number one
you know but actually
that doesn't always stand the pressure
test of time and of life and of going
for big things are always going to
be humbling and i think the thing is do
your best you know it's dip dip dip you
know dyb do your best i i love that
because wherever you're at
you can do that you know it's a decision
isn't it it's not a gift it's not
something we're born with like the looks
or the academic of the sport is
something you've got to summon
and uh
i like that what were the symptoms of
having a lack of confidence when you
were that age what would it look like
how did it manifest itself
i think probably just being quite shy
and uh
and
i think you see the the people at school
always the the bigger personalities and
it was always like gosh you got to be
like that to get anywhere and it's a
life journey isn't it to realize
it's almost the opposite
it's almost the opposite
you know look at the quiet the
persevering
relentlessly trying to put yourself up
through the failures and and keep going
and and
know the wealth of life the wealth has
always found in our relationships and
and
you know you come across people who are
rich in friendships and you know rich
and passionate and love what they do and
love the people they work with and
you know and that's enough that's
wonderful
but it takes a bit of unlearning doesn't
it of saying
you know you don't have the people not
always to look up to aren't always front
and center and as i get older i see more
and more heroes left right and center
where more left and right rather than
center
you know and i love that i i sort of
see it in people and uh
you know i see it in our camera crew i
mean look at look at what's been a
cool part of my job for however many
years many years now you know the
filming and stuff and
you know the focus is always on the
person front to screen and you know that
horrible word of talent as they call it
i never felt very talented still don't
still feel i'm surrounded by way more
talented people but it's life isn't a
competition about who's mortality it's a
it's a journey to
take with great friends and i look at
our camera crew and to me true heroes
you know they work harder
they carry heavier weights you know
unsung
you know relentlessly positive
carry me many times you know in so many
ways encourage me when
when i've been struggling and i look at
them and and still brothers and sisters
best friends to this day uh
i think it's probably the thing i'm most
proud of in my career actually are the
friendships with our crew you know in an
industry that
is notoriously transient you know people
have crew come kruger new crews you know
but we've kept pretty well the core crew
from
from the beginning
and uh
part of it's that we're obviously
working in difficult dangerous terrain
and you forge stronger bonds than you
would in a shiny studio
but
part of it is that the loyalty really
matters from both
goes both ways
uh and i love that
you said that you kind of have a bit of
an allergic reaction to the word talent
right just from a few other things that
you said in that little opener i
wondered if you
you relate at all to the to the phrase
imposter syndrome at all because you're
someone who's the world
has this image of you as being this like
unbelievable mountain scaling fearless
adventurer and even you talking about a
lack of confidence doesn't seem to fit
into that narrative that the world must
hold of you so have you ever felt
what they call imposter syndrome at all
would you ever yeah i think so because
i'm going because then it probably grows
you know the more you know the more sort
of something does well you know we
you know we we did the show this year
for netflix called you versus wild you
know and we just got the news you know
this morning we got um nominated for
three emmys for it
and the crew got better he's so excited
but part of my heart dies part of me is
like oh it's like that gulf between
the the sort of tv sort of you know guy
and the re gets bigger you know and i
feel
from day one i felt
i almost had more confidence i think in
my skills at the beginning i think as
the years have gone on and i've realized
actually i've often be surrounded by
people who are better better climbers
better skydivers better survival guys
better looking fitter stronger all of
these things just because we've built a
a crew of ninjas of true heroes and you
know got to work with people and locals
and experts all around the world
year after year
and i think more and more i feel these
guys are those that person we met there
or that person they are amazing be much
better at the job than me
but you know like i say our our job
isn't to be the best you know it's to do
our best and and you know for some
reason i've been given this this the
chance to do this it's what i've always
loved i love the adventures i love like
i say the friendships and you know the
job we do and
i think you can only ride that'd be
grateful for it and
and like i say do do your best and and
not worry about
too much about
how the tv makes it always look i mean
the truth is the tv always puts the best
bits they cut out the trips and the
stumbles and you put anything into music
and the guy's gonna look cool you know
but i think an element to why the show
worked when we first started doing it is
that we did show a lot of the mistakes
and it was kind of
the slips and the stumbles and the ums
and the r's and i remember from day one
that the producer that came
came to me and said we want to do this
show where we drop you in the middle of
difficult places and you show us how to
get out of there and and i kept saying
no because i didn't want to do tv i
didn't know about tv and i was like
and
you know but you kept saying we don't
want that it doesn't need to be perfect
and i've and it was my wife i said what
are you gonna try you know and i just
left the military we just got married we
were kind of starting out and
she was smart she said go and try it and
actually it's never felt like making a
perfect thing i think the magic at that
time it was the first show that came
along that let all the mud be on the
lens and the rain on the lens and the
trips and the stumbles and you saw the
cameraman's hand and it would come there
was an a sort of interactivity that was
there was great and i've always thought
if it's not broke don't fix it the
stumbles the trips the struggles the
mistakes are part of life
uh
but the part of my heart that dies is if
it goes it all makes it look too good or
too you know because at the end of the
day i'm a really regular guy i'm a
regular
dad as well you know i'm not i'm not
brilliant at any of these things but i
know what i love and i know
the weapons that serve me best and the
weapons are always this you know be
dogged be determined
be be the most resilient person out
there when it's hard you know come alive
in the big moments
when it's not the big moments you don't
need to be front and center but in the
big moments be there
i watched a lot of interviews of you
before you you arrived here today and i
think in pretty much all of them you
said i'm a normal guy i'm a regular guy
and i get that i get that i understand
what you're saying however
well it's not false modesty i don't want
to i'm not going to let people
build
build me into something i'm not you know
and i think as i get older i know the
frailties more and more and i'm not
ashamed of them you know i mean it's
it's okay many mistakes many many
struggles it's okay otherwise things
become all too
you know that how
it's hard to relate to you know
but you you got through sas selection
just i got through all these hit just
you know and people turned turned to you
and and said things and as they turn
back and quit
right that that for me is a filtering
process of something yeah whatever that
something is
all it is is it's something we can
control it's not a filtering of talent
it's not a filtering of you you're
brilliant you're through you're not
through you know it's a genius of
selection for the special forces it's
all about heart and spirit and we can
all have that that's not a god-given
talent that's a that's a muscle that
builds with
walking through the door of failure time
and time again and keep getting back up
you know so
i like that that's why i say i am an
ordinary person as well i also say just
to so many things because you know yes
i've passed out oh yes you reach the top
of this man or yes you do but it's
always just
and that's okay you know and it's also
often
by standing on the shoulders of many
giants who have helped me you know many
many times you know if i think of
ss selection you know that time there
were so many times where
somebody somebody just kind of believed
me in a critical time you know it might
be something where the two corporals
running something goes we want that guy
doing you know a bit of luck falls on
your side somebody backs you you know or
you know you i don't know just
the more i look back on so many
so-called achievements the more i see
the hand of good people in critical
moments but as you know you have to win
the hearts of those people in the first
place
but also
the role of just that dogged
determination to keep going and that's
not
a thing of being brilliant it's just
trying to keep going often sliding
another step back but keep moving
forward
and you say that to you know i've got
three boys now three teenagers and i
think if you said to them what one thing
does your dad say to you day off day
before you go to school
it's always just
you know don't give up don't never give
up be kind you know be determined but
never give up
and they roll their eyes but you know
what
one day they'll know that
it's a key thing a key thing of life you
know you don't have to
be the best to do your best
did that
resilience muscle as you call it grow
over time
of course it's just like like everything
it's like the little little seas to the
mighty oaks you know we how do we build
it just inch by inch
and uh
and that's a great thing because it's
not something only some people can have
you know it's universal for us all we
can all become people think it's a
god-given gift to someone be resilient
resilience is that muscle and you build
it by failing and trying to stay
positive and trying to get back your
feet and going again you know i look
back and
i remember being uh really excited about
being picked for the
fourth eleven football team as a
linesman
it wasn't even in the team you know
and it was like my job was to bring on
the oranges uh half time
you know but it was like and i remember
my dad was the only dad on the side of
the pitch cheering me on i thought it
was so embarrassing he's not i'm not
even in the team and dad said you know
he's come to kind of
but actually those little steps of like
i'm gonna do this i'm gonna bring on
those oranges and you know you're never
gonna forget it's gonna be great
and it's
incremental tiny little things
but
having to fight for things you know so
how often do we see at school though the
the school hero
actually in life
doesn't always do that brilliantly and
why is that it's because they've got you
know schools rewarded that
but they've never tested this
you know where little johnny who doesn't
have that doesn't get the awards
it's a linesman brings on the oranges
yeah whatever it is struggles doesn't
even get noticed never wins anything but
never gives up and keeps doing his best
and still doesn't really get noticed but
doesn't matter but when he leaves school
this might not be the biggest thing but
this is like ninja like you know that
that resilience muscle inside is strong
and as you know and as i know in life
that's the one that
is going to
carry you further
and
and the unseen people at school often
do better in life it's like don't peak
too early don't peak at 14.
i certainly didn't i sat here with um
eubank i've been thinking about this
idea of resilience and what it really
means and as we sit here today my
current hypothesis is basically
resilience is the story it's kind of
this contract you have with yourself
this self-story about who you are and in
those moments when no one is looking i i
was talking to eubank about me being on
the running machine and knowing i've got
two minutes to go because i said before
i started i'd run until 45 minutes
but my legs are hurting and they're
cramping and i could give up and walk
away and no one's gonna know because no
one's here yeah what i i alter my own
self story in a way and i i send a
message to myself that i am the type of
person that gives up when it's tough so
is it really do you relate to that and
this kind of like you're crafting this
story about who you are to yourself with
every small decision you make doing the
linesman job you said i'm gonna do it
the best i possibly can
and although it's not what i wanted i'm
gonna i'm gonna give it everything i can
and not give up yeah
yeah does that relate and also i think
the thing of giving up is that
you know what is this i think of
temporary pleasure long term yeah that's
not true you know and and for me i just
i i develop thing where
[Music]
whenever people quitting or complaining
i like those moments for me it was like
okay there's all the all the chat and
the bravado there's always that
beginning i was full of that but bring
it down put the squeeze on you know we
like grapes squeeze this you see what's
inside bring the squeeze bring the
squeeze now we see character you see
what people are like
and for me it just became whenever i saw
people quitting or complaining
especially complaining you see it so
much just
in the military you see it on big
expeditions you see it even when we're
filming tv shows with people you know
when it gets hard
you know and you're hungry and you're
scared and you're up against it you're
dehydrated you know those are the
moments and for me it just became a
trigger when everyone's complaining and
giving up so time to give more you know
just you don't have to give more in the
early times just wait until it's
and that's how you separate yourselves
in in business and in life and in
relationship you know in the big moments
you know look at a relationship when
it's when you're under that real time
and everyone's throwing it you know are
you going to really throw that nasty
comment or kind of hold it and just
try and be gracious and kind in those
big moments you know
and and i like that it wasn't
you know it wasn't complicated to think
about under pressure it was just like
when everything's going wrong that's the
time to give more rather than give up
and i held on to that in many difficult
moments you know across many different
arenas
and um
and it's helped me you know i remember
this guy said to me once said and you do
anything for another 10 seconds
i like that you know when it's you're in
that moment you key going another 10
seconds
that makes you different though
you got to admit because most people
don't want another 10 seconds yeah well
it hurt it hurts i'm not saying it's not
going to hurt it's going to hurt but
that fire inside it's in this in us all
you know it's just you've got to dig
sometimes but it's
it's a great truth to know that it's
there when you dig you know it is there
and uh and i think as you say once you
get used to it and you start to practice
it the muscle gets stronger and then you
almost seek out tough times you know
this is a chance to
to shine you know and as you say that's
how you separate yourselves
in life you know you're going to reach
these points but but in those big amount
what are you going to go this way how
are you going to act in those big
moments and it's always what separates
you know reaching those summits for not
reaching those summits never give up
it's the name of your
latest book when is there a time to give
up
because there is a wildly believed i
think social phrase which is like
quitting is for losers right but some
when i look at my own life and my own
career quitting has played quite an
important role sometimes in leaving a
situation that wasn't good so when
should we give up well that's called
wisdom and it comes with experience and
there's always there's always a right
first of all my 16 year old nephew came
to me the other day i said i said bev
you
need a not the smoking on the head
you're smoking a lot at the moment
he went but ever since i have a kid you
told me never give up
i said apart from the cigarettes you
know there's always a time to give
things and some and experience and
wisdom
you know you just don't want to be a
pig-headed head in the dirt
you know that's not smart that's not
smart you know intuition and experience
has to know when hard on this is this
isn't maybe the right route let's just
take a step back
and i think it's why so often
great mountaineers are often a little
bit older
because they have that patience and that
judgment and when you're young and you
don't care and you kind of maybe should
be listening to that intuition and maybe
the weather's changed or something's
happening that's saying hold you know
and you go and you die that's why why so
many higher tude mountaineers deaths is
that that
you know relentless ability not to adapt
or change your plan where with age you
have that ability to listen to your
instinct to the mountains to the
circumstances and maybe adapt and maybe
change and as we know you know with big
mountains they'll always be there so i
think that ability to life to listen
to that
and to amend and to adapt super
important and look at soldiering same as
always this thinking man soldier you
know was a was a mantra of a lot of
these special forces stuff was always
being able to adapt improvise adapt
overcome you know that that's that's
leading with this and with this
so
course is a time
for pulling back and holding
but i think generally the message you
know 90 percent of the time
most people don't get where they're
going not
not because of a lack of skills or
talent is it's that lack of kind of
ability to keep going when it's hard
and that's why i think doing
little things every day
small things that you know whatever it
is that just push your push this muscle
a bit is good you know even if it's like
i mean i have i've had a thing for years
and it's now super popular everyone's
kind of you know doing it you know the
ice bath training yeah but i've done it
for years and i love this thing it's
just three minutes a day i'm just in
that cold water you know whether it's a
river or in winter or lake or you know
at night time and you know i try and
find somewhere every day just get in
that cold and it hurts still hurts but
it's just a little some little something
whatever it is that's your something
that's difficult to do
because most people spend their lives
avoiding the the painful the difficult
you know they're scared of public
speaking or they're scared so they avoid
the things that
challenge us but as you know is where
growth happens and growth isn't always
fun it's often painful but it's like a
muscle the more you push it the more you
get used to it you know there's a great
thing at the commando training center in
limston that just says comfortable with
uncertainty and it's a great thing for
life you know don't get sat in that
comfort zone
too much you know i call it a comfort
pit somewhere to get out
i was wondering if like training in the
gym
when i
do my repetitions of the weights i then
need a bigger weight to get the same
gain
so do you find yourself needing like a
bigger thrill or a bigger expedition or
a greater challenge to get the same like
feeling of fulfillment and contempt from
what your work these days and where did
you find that after you've climbed
everest and done all you've done
i i don't feel that no you don't i don't
feel that i think um
what you're saying in the question is
you actually is that where you get your
fulfillment through that thing and the
answer is no it's not where i get
fulfillment fulfillment i do these
things i try and do the difficult things
just to keep that inside muscle honed a
little bit but it's not always about
bigger and better and
you know it's
as i read the other day half of life is
getting to where you
you know achieving your goals and the
other half of life has been really
happy to enjoy it
second one's a harder one to do
and i think a big you know i'd be super
lucky to fulfill so many things i still
have many goals many ambitions but it's
not goals and ambitions that trump the
last one are ever bigger and uh
you know it's not like that it's just
really grateful and try
make sure you stay alive you know make
sure you're always grateful for the many
good things and the luck you've had
along the way
you know keep that muscle inside honed
keep working keep doing your best
but it's definitely not where i find the
fulfillment it's not it's not like
the achievement's never going to fulfill
that whole did you used to think it
would
maybe a little bit i think when i was
young you know i think everest certainly
for me was such a symbol of like i'm
gonna do this you know that it was at a
time when
only i think 20 odd brits had ever
climbed it and it was i thought this is
going to be epic you know and and then
you see the realities of you know we
have four climbers lose their lives up
there and it re-rattled me in many ways
and i was lucky to reach the top and got
back in one piece but it didn't answer
that question of
you know
i i don't know i don't think i'd climb
it now i'm not so out on a quest to kind
of prove
anything but i think when you're young
it's
half of it's good to have a quest you
know you've got to have that goal
but the other half is like it's not it's
not the answer to life is it you know
it's it's a
you know that maybe comes from elsewhere
and with time and experience you learn
the real answer life has always
rooted in
you know something inside and that and
relationships with great people and
you know a lot of it i think comes down
to love actually you know being uh
knowing those connections with great
people and a love of whatever it could
be can be love of the outdoors the love
of what you do you know
but um
it's not found an achievement always
have you found
where it is found you don't seem to be
so
certain exactly where that that feeling
of fulfillment um
[Music]
you talked about the second half which
is like enjoying the goals
have you figured that bit out i think
it's a lifelong journey of figuring
it out you know i i hope i edge closer
to where it's not found
which is is never found in trophies and
triumphs and accolades you know those
things i see those things with clearer
lenses now you know i'm more proud of to
be married you know 22 years you know i
got three
great boys you know the the simpler
things i'm i'm more proud of i think
you know where do i really find
fulfillment i think um
i think my faith is a quiet thing
in that sense
you know face always a tricky one but
and hard to articulate very well but
it's definitely comes from a place of
like
that you're
you're okay you're okay we're we're
forgiven we're loved empowered
and um trying to live it live life as
best you can eyes wide open with
you know gratitude in your heart and a
tough resilient spirit to go for things
and uh and i look at life in those sort
of turns more and more i feel like in
the in the 2022 in the uk where i think
we've grown more atheist as a society
i mean
some people say there's no such thing as
an atheist but we've grown more atheists
in our viewpoints
it is harder to communicate if you do
have a faith
why did you say that it's a it's a
tricky thing
i think it's been so tarnished i think
religion has been so tarnished and i i
get that i was always the least
religious person growing up i just
thought i mean as a kid i had a really
natural faith i always believed in some
higher power and that
i could feel you know there's something
around you know as a little kid it was
like ah wow
and then i think i went to school and
then you know you had to go to church
and they were all white classics and
spoken latin i thought
gosh i've really missed it you know this
is actually what it's about and it's
been a life journey to unwind all of
that and realize actually
the little me had it right
you know faith is faith is in your heart
knowing knowing that you're not alone
and and
there's something bigger than us out
there and
they're for us not you know that power
is for us not against us and
despite my doubts and all of those sort
of things i'm gonna put my trust in that
and try and
you know
have love at the center of what we do
and live empowered and go for things and
not be scared to fail and
not be driven by fear and all those sort
of things and that to me what faith is
um
so it's hard to articulate i think
because it's
personal and it's it's
intimate and also it's like i say it's
it's has just as many doubts as it does
you know doubt and faith two sides of
the same coin you know i think
it does feel like that for me but
through it all
i would say my christian faith has been
a real backbone and a kind of secret
strength in many
tricky moments you know
light to a dark path i always kind of
feel it's that sort of thing so yeah i
did wonder when i was reading about your
faith and i watched you pray for obama
just at the end of your time with him
because i've sat here with guests who
have undergone and witnessed such
horrific things in their
in their lives and they've and it's
shaking their faith in fact eubank was
one of them that his brother suddenly
died they were both very religious and
that shook his faith and being out in
nature and being on those expeditions up
everest where two people fall to their
death and twos you know die of the cold
one would it might assume that those
moments would shake your your faith but
it sounds like it's made it stronger in
a way from what you said well i think
the two things happen often you get
shaken and strengthened
and uh actually my experience with
people people who've really been taken
to the edge
that's actually where they find their
faith you know you look at so many of
the concentration camp stories and stuff
you know
it's uh
you know two sides looking at one person
said
there can be no god i've seen i've
witnessed
evil personified and
yeah it was if i can't remember when and
said
i've been to the edge and i know there's
no place that god isn't
you know it's all how we look at how we
choose to live
and uh
i choose to choose to try and live with
you know faith faith in other people
faith in ourselves faith in the almighty
and that and that helped me but it's
it's funny that thing with obama because
in a way that was never meant to be on
tv it was just a spontaneous thing at
the end of the journey and i'd you know
as you know when you spend time with
people
you get a sense of someone and i think
at the end of that journey with obama i
got a real sense that
he's a guy with a weight of the world on
his shoulders you know and he he got
lighter as the journey went on and by
the end he said you know what's one of
the best days of my presidency i'm out
of the office i'm out of a suit
talking about stuff that's in here
rather than being grilled on
you know politics and
and i could see him light getting
lighter you know and i just said it yeah
i said it first of all
good job you're doing you you probably
i don't know if you get told it very
often most people are giving your heart
a bit you know you're doing your best
you know and i want to just say you know
i don't feel like let's reef try and
refill his fuel tank a bit yeah yeah and
actually it ended up going in the show
you know i put a hand on his shoulder
and said you know
strength this guy you know the big
decisions
oh man you know and it wasn't really
more complicated than that but
i don't know i think the wild
always creates
honest connections without the fluff
and it didn't feel unnatural and
you know but it's funny how the effect
of that i still get people to this day
talk about that a lot i know quite
unlikely people often say that wasn't
that was a good good moment
not always easy i mean awkward sometimes
isn't it doing that sort of thing
of course but but that's okay i've
learned that
that's okay dude sometimes the awkward
things
are the best things
telling someone that
you know
you know that they're amazing you know
can be awkward to a good friend but can
can mean a lot
quick one we bring in eight people a
month to watch these conversations live
here in the studio when we're here in
the uk and when we're in la if you want
to be one of those people all you've got
to do is hit subscribe
you said earlier about being rattled
after everest one would never
assume that of course you climb the
biggest mountain in the world
and you come down and you're rattled and
your confidence is knocked
i think big mantas are humbling you know
and sometimes you you take on these big
projects and it's about come on we're
gonna do it and you're you're full of
that
confidence
but um but it's often quite surface and
i think when you see things close up and
it it
i think i came away with a real
awareness of that i've been really lucky
and got away with my life where others
hunt up there and this stage everest was
killing one in six people's lives you
know and beforehand i read about that
and it was almost kind of it was almost
glamorous it was almost like romantic
you know but you see the see the reality
of it close up and it's it's not
romantic it's it's
dark and and difficult and confusing
and uh and i think my feeling at the end
of it was that i got really lucky you
know i've been no doubt dug deep in a
few big moments and
you know it was some
92 days on that mountain there's a lot
of time to do have to dig deep but
ultimately i had a bit of luck at key
times
and i think i came away aware of that
and and grateful for that but less
certain that just because you're
determined in life doesn't mean
everything's going to go well you know
and i think beforehand i kind of thought
if you give over this we're going to
work out but as you know in everything
in life there's no guarantees you know
we're
we we live a gloves off life
you know life is gloves off there no
rules of kind of like if you if you give
this school going to be
you know roses and sunshine you know you
can give the best in the world it's
going to be
hit you sometimes you know you get ill
or something happens and i think
that's the part of me that got a bit
shaken and
but you know that's just life and you
have to
live with your eyes wide open to that
and and still choose to try and make the
good decisions and pick the good
attitudes and put them on like a t-shirt
every day that even though gloves are
off we're gonna go for this we're gonna
do our best to be positive do our best
to give our best
and keep going for it
those four people that passed away were
they climbing with you
two russians and a
a brit new new zealander from other
teams
but they're larry on the mountain at the
same time and and never came back and i
remember with their teammates you know
afterwards just
them in tears and sitting with them and
it definitely made me question a lot of
the time is is any mountain really worth
a life i wish you clear answers no
but at the time sometimes your ambition
is you know it's like we're gonna go for
it and and that's why i think now kind
of with a bit of time and experience
would i
would i do it now would i take a one or
six chance of not coming home no no
because you have more to live for
but i think at the time i was like i'm
all in i'm going to go i want to make my
mark you know at a young age
and uh and the truth is i got lucky
fame
but yeah what does that one mean
yeah you tell me only on the tv for a
couple of minutes i mean
so but you've been on there for
many many many many years so i was
hoping maybe you could give me a little
bit of an overview of what
fame is
because you know when i looked at bear
grylls podcast
and i really couldn't find much there
was for someone that's been in the
public eye for so long could barely find
anything
and then i read this quote that you you
don't like
sometimes you feel like when you meet
someone there's a sense of you're
worried you might disappoint them
because they're expecting you to be
something else
well i think that's true
i think part of my kind of
the answer is i don't do very many of
these you know i think um
but that's okay i'm not sort of hungry
for more
people to know
everything you know i do
do these sort of things every now and
again with with good people and and
when it feels right
you know i think i think one of the
reasons i get i get less comfortable
sometimes in big groups of people and
and doing press circle doings you know i
i'm not very i don't really like the
cameras on me if i'm honest i struggle
really with that so one you know i never
gone to tv for that you know i got to tv
because you know this producer said do
you want to try this thing and
like i said we were just married and
starting out and pretty broke and it was
like let's go for it let's see what see
what happens but the sort of the
recognition side of things you know i
struggle with the word fame i think it's
a weird one
but i think the recognition side of
things i
i struggle with more um and i think part
of it is
a little part of me feels i'm never
going to be quite as good as people
expect you know in in
as a tv sometimes makes out and
therefore
less is more very happy with my family
and friends and i go and work but i want
to kind of come home afterwards
but when it comes to
fame you know you say that you say about
that i've
i kind of learned i think over the years
too first we'll take it with a
not just a pinch of salt but with a
bucket of salt you know don't believe it
it doesn't
it's not where your worth is your word
you know if your worth is that you're
always going to struggle because it goes
up and down there's ultimately it's
going down isn't it you know you're you
know when we're when we're 95 years old
nobody's going to know who who i am
yourself
well but but and it doesn't matter you
know it doesn't but our sense of
self-worth you're always going to be
fighting a losing battle really yeah
yeah so i take it all with a bucket of
salt
um i think for my family growing up with
a little bit of that they've i always
say to our boys growing up
we got friends all over the world and
look at it like that amazing connections
you know i can go to
go to any country and and there's a
connection with with with people there
and people want to tell their stories
and go oh i've just been camping with my
you know my son or my you know my uncle
was this or did that or my son's a scout
daughter's a scout or whatever it is and
i like those connections always grateful
for people's stories and
and that's fine so that's how i kind of
look at it pinch yourself don't believe
it all but uh always be grateful for
friends all over the world did you
struggle with it
i think i struggled with it when i felt
the attention was on me i think i didn't
like that that that felt i remember so
well in the early days when we started
doing man versus wild
first two seasons we were just gunning
and going and it was all just kind of
fun out there a small crew i never
really didn't see it go down tell you it
was going out in america at the time so
i was over in the uk i didn't see it i
didn't know what was happening it was
just lucky it was good timing and it
just worked you know it just was meant
to be at that time but i didn't really
see much of that because i come home and
you know live regularly and i remember
the head of discovery after a couple of
seasons say you know your show's
best on discovery it's getting over a
billion viewers now around the world
and uh
and my heart sank i really started to
struggle with it and i suddenly started
that when we were filming i'd be like
self-conscious and what am i saying and
holidays
and
the fun went out of it and my i got more
anxious with it all and i thought i
don't want people looking at this or
doing this or
and it was a really sort of marked time
of
and the crew said it so they said is
everything okay
and i think
i had to learn to
it's about other people you know and
when i raised people coming up and they
weren't going
you know you're amazing there we go
i took my son camping or or my whatever
did that and when i was it was about
them and i'd really try to shift it in
my brain everything's about them you
know it's what it brings out whether
it's a single mom coming to me saying
when he once said about you're in that
storm in the jungle and you said
sometimes life is it's going to beat you
up and you just got to be dogged and
keep going keep your head down you know
the storms won't last forever and i
really understood that as a single man i
was trying to hold down all these jobs
i've got you know that for me lifted my
whole
i thought that's why i do this job
and it kind of shifted it
off me and and and and that's why i've
always loved my job now as like chief
scout you know for me that was a
revolution to be able to say when people
come up to me and go you know oh you've
done this now yeah but look what you
could do you could join you know you
could join that and you can do this and
you know somewhere to be able to
not deflect but sort of direct people a
little bit
and i i get such a kick out of that it's
why i love running wild so much because
it's about other people it's about
taking these rookies they might be
amazing rookies but
they're often wilderness rookies and
opening their eyes to
my office you know the outdoors what the
wire can do for people that light inside
that pride that come on you know that
magic
and uh and saying look at this and that
freed me a lot
away from kind of
look at look at you know
look that way instead of this way
you said a word though which i i started
thinking about a lot which was the word
anxiety
which i actually think is quite an
interesting thing because you're much of
your work is about the natural world and
one of the i think unnatural human
signals is anxiety it kind of tells you
something that you're potentially doing
wrong maybe a train of thought that
you've attached yourself to which is
destructive or whatever else and
depression's one of those things is what
i talk about a lot is also seems to be a
pretty clear signal for a natural signal
that we have you know some of my guests
have said that they have it's a signal
that they've been disconnected from
their tribe and it's and they've
explained the science of that and um and
even the signal of rejection and how
that makes us feel is a prehistoric
signal telling us to get back into our
tribe because or that there's a chance
we might be thrown off the island by our
tribe because we're being rejected so to
change our behavior and all of these
signals
anxiety depression and this whole mental
health um
awareness that's emerged in the last 10
years
what's your relationship been like with
those with those um
those topics
first of all it's it's amazing that
people are talking about this and
focusing on it more you know i think
you know it's it's long overdue and it's
a key part of our arsenal for life isn't
it our weapons that are gonna
help make your heart happy you know you
you need to
you need to look after the physical you
need to look after the emotional you
need to look after spiritual and you
need to look after the mental side of
things you know it's all these are all
weapons in our arsenal we've got to
focus on and if you neglect one
there's always going to be a little part
of your heart that is
going to struggle a bit if you if you
whether it's emotional physical or
mental so you've got to
try and put things in place that help
your mental health
and
and i think people for many years often
neglected that you shut things away but
actually the so many of the things that
help us mentally are simple things like
as you say those connections to people
and that honesty and vulnerability and
and like we've been talking about not
letting yourself sort of live a life
that actually isn't real not letting
people make you into that hero that you
don't always fear you know stay honest
stay connected talk to people you know
be outside how how many times do we see
studies proving that when we're outside
and we're in the sun and we're
expressing and we're working hard and
we're connected to people that's why the
wild is such an amazing
mental health
weapon to
build up that resource you know in a
world that often depletes the resource
you know all of this stuff is always
pulling you know if i pulling pulling
you know
leaves you emptier but for me the wild
and connection and the sun and outdoors
and swimming cold rivers and
challenge and failing and all these sort
of things build up
i find for me help my mental health you
can't take your off the ball with mental
health you gotta
and you're not always gonna get it right
and that's okay
is there a time in your life where you
discovered mental health was a
very real thing because of an experience
that you'd had
because i think for many years i thought
it was something that happened to other
people and then there's a couple of sort
of catalystic events that happened in my
life that made me realize that i am not
immune to anxiety to feelings you know
depressive symptoms and all of those
things but is there something in your
life where there's a pivotal moment
where life events typically are the
catalyst of those things where you go
this is something that i now need to put
as a priority
i think i've been lucky in the sense
that i've i've never suffered from
really bad depression you know where
many many friends i've stood alongside
have really had battles i think i've
always had a
you know an intuition of when i need to
change something and when i'm struggling
a little bit and when hold on this
this feeling of of anxiety would be
going on a bit oh what can we change
what helps me and i've always sort of
accidentally
found things
that help make that
problem better and for me it's been that
go to being outdoors being with great
friends having a few
just a few good friends rather than lots
and lots of friends you know even things
like our our be military fit our bmf or
veterans run fitness business has helped
me so much because it's a collective
tribe of
you know often veterans
people who need that camaraderie but
want to train want to stay physically
fit don't want to be in a gym inside
with
white light and all of that they want to
be outside in the fresh air they want to
be down in the dirt a little bit they
want to laugh at themselves in
situations and face a few you know rain
swept early mornings training outside in
a park together and and
like our physical health the more we can
be aware of the things that do help and
have proven to help
and to gravitate towards so seek those
things in our life be outside be
connected train
you know be honest have a few friends
the more it's gonna help us when we do
have the dark moments and
i've never met anyone who doesn't have
them you know they might tell you they
don't but everyone has these moments and
i certainly i certainly have and
but i've also never met a strong person
who's had an easy past you know it's
just
part of it if you're gonna go for big
things you're gonna shoot for the top
you're gonna have struggles and failures
and
part of life when was your darkest
moment
one was when i broke my back in the
military and was in
rehabilitation for a long time and you
know so much of my rock in my life had
been that i was physically strong and i
was doing a job i loved and suddenly i
couldn't even reach the bathroom without
excruciating agony and you know my back
broken in three places and
you know that
you know i had to then leave my job
you know with the military and and it
was just a what am i going to do with my
life you know but i also look at that
time and i think
if i had gone through that i don't think
i ever would have actually had the drive
and the impetus to make that everest
expedition happen at that young age and
have hadn't done that that wouldn't have
opened the door to other things and then
eventually the tv and you know it's like
it's like these
these clouds that often you know it's
why not to be scared when life does hit
you sideways because there's often a
sort of a plan there you just
gotta try and
keep moving forward towards it but
that was definitely a dark time and i
think also losing my dad at a young age
i mean
shara and my wife and me both lost our
parents within 10 weeks of each other in
year one of marriage and it was we were
young we were 24 25
and uh just starting out on life and i
think we always had that safety net of
our parents behind us you know and and i
think suddenly both losing our dads and
now being responsible for our mums and
it was uh it definitely took that safety
net away and it was like wow we're both
dealing with trauma here
not always very well but we we gotta i
mean
i look back now and actually it's what
made us made us really tight
and to have a love and a trust and a
vulnerability together that has been a
key thing in our relationship i think
ever since but at the time it was just
pure pain
and a and a huge
hole that
is still there to the day you know i
mean you know seeing our three boys grow
up great the great loss for me is that
you know they will never know my dad or
he would never know them and how like he
was they are and all of these dynamics
that we
take for granted and so often i see
friends now and they get oh my you know
my mum's a bit poorly and my dad i'm
thinking there's part of me thinking you
know you're so lucky to have had your
parents for that long and we i was
dealing with looking after
my mom and all her sort of bills and
everything and you know when i was 25
you know it's been going on a long time
but
but at the same time i think my dad
told me so many of the key things in
life which was back to the earlier point
of like
you know be resilient and be kind and
keep going and and those things
i'll always be grateful for and i wish
my only regret is that i'd get a chance
to say to him
wow you were right you were actually
right all along when i kicked against it
and kind of you know you were right
you know fully dreams be kind be
resilient
never give up and uh i never said thank
you enough for that
that's something i always worry about
my dad is has outlived his siblings
and um
i don't feel like i've made enough of an
effort to stay connected there's
something about us where we just think
our parents are going to be around
forever like you when you see the safety
blanket thing it's like this it's almost
like it reminds me of covid where i
didn't realize the tectonic plate of
society could ever move so i built my
life like ignorantly on this foundation
that society would be open and that and
then one day someone showed me that
there was even a tectonic plate
underneath me that i didn't know was
there and my parents are the same thing
they've just always been there so i
assume naively that they always will be
but um
what would you say to what advice would
you give me about
well never take that for granted
and never never be scared of saying i
mean
tell him now you know tell him on this
he'll listen to this
he's probably incredibly
incredibly proud of you
all you've achieved superseded his
wildest dreams of what a sun could be
and he should be proud and
tell him
what would you tell your dad if he was
anything maybe well i think i'd i'll say
thank you for for the little things
you know it's not that it's thanks for
being there on that touch line when i
was linesman
you know thanks for not putting too much
focus just on
success
and school reports and
being top
thank you very focused on
being kind and having a dream
even though it might not be the path
most trodden
you know but
but go for it if it's your dream go for
it
and thanks for saying that never give up
is the golden currency of life
rather than you know good looks
uh sporty talent or academic brilliance
but you know i think um
for you your dad your dad knows you know
i'm sure he knows but
never stop telling him
you know because
i think really parental relationships
one of those ones that's always going to
be they're always going to be dynamics
and struggles and
fallouts and arguments stuff but
you can never articulate it too much
that you love someone and you can never
overestimate how much those simple
awkward difficult words to say
mean i mean my great buddy
said
he really wanted to tell his dad one
time he loved him but he knew he was so
english he wouldn't his father it would
be a really difficult thing to say
and eventually said i'm going to say to
and he said dad i just want to just let
you know i really love you and this song
his dad goes
you've been drinking
you know but the thing is that's okay
your dad would go home that night
knowing that he hadn't been drinking the
guy his son hadn't been drinking but
that was special and i think those
awkwardness backed up thing of doing
sometimes the awkward difficult things
like the prayer with obama
is a really good thing you know and i've
tried to get better at this in my life
of
saying thank you and and doing nice
things and say saying awkward
but
good things to people i mean i said it
to my great buddy the other day rupert i
said to him
you know
we work a lot together and stuff so i
said you know forget the work side of
these you
you're such a lovely friend
and yeah i literally saw boom i saw the
eyes well out just for a second you know
and it was like you know are you oh
you're great i know it's
keep training or whatever you're doing
you know but it's sometimes the awkward
things are the good things
and um i hope as i
live and do more in life that i i create
more and more of those moments because
there are many people i'm
like i said i stand on the shoulders of
many giants that are the real heroes in
my life and i definitely consider my dad
one i'd definitely consider those i
served alongside the military many still
friends to this day and when i was with
corporal williams my old you know
squadron
you know patrol commander who's now aged
you know
70
and uh lives in martha tidfield i was
with him the other day for a walk in the
brecons
just remind him i go you've been an
amazing friend through life and i'll
never forget the belief you had in me in
the early days thank you you know
i consider the camera crew i work with
in that same vein
and uh
never take those for granted
quick one i just wanted to share a
fantastic initiative from one of my
podcast sponsors for those of you that
are looking to grow your business online
right now you can get 200 pounds of
social media advertising paid for by
vodafone business when you sign up to
three unlimited mobile plans social
media has a huge impact on your business
if i had to start my business again from
scratch right now the first thing i
would do is produce content daily at a
high cadence the thing that grew my
company so fast was producing content on
social media platforms it helps your
company become known and build your
digital reputation slash personal brand
if you've not ventured into the space of
social media or social media advertising
before don't worry vodafone business
will also provide the knowledge support
and tips you need in creating a plan all
through vodafone vhub to find out more
and how i'd spend that 200 pounds at
vodafone giving search vodafone digital
boost and obviously terms and conditions
apply
as you might know my energy are a
sponsor of this podcast and they offer
countless ways to make your life a
little bit more sustainable and make
that transition from where you are now
to a sustainable life 10 times easier
their products are all about energy
independence allowing you to create a
greener home through their
cost-effective and super user-friendly
products and one of my favorite products
right now is the zappy it's a smart ev
charger which simply allows you to
charge your electric vehicle from solar
or wind power so if you would like to
find out more about my energy then head
to myenergy.com and if you've tried the
zappy let me know how you got on with it
in the comments section below
your wonderful wife
i remember you saying once upon a time
if you really want to know someone
you've got to ask the wife and kids
what they're like you know such a isn't
it i mean
what if i asked your wife what would she
say what would she say about the
flawed [ __ ] probably says flawed
flawed
but you know
in what way i think loyalty and and
sticking through things and knowing the
real us and and that we're not perfect
and we we're
there for each other's is creates a
power to it and i do look at
relationships that are special like
you know with your kids or with your
wife as like stained glass you know you
need to
they're really beautiful
but you've got to protect them and
you've got to protect them number one
and i think it's so easy in life to do
the opposite actually we take that one
for granted and we produce our best
we produce our best for the
at the dinner party to hold court and
say the jokes and you know and it's the
wrong way round you know it's the wrong
way round save your best
i think it's saying i've learned and
still try and i don't always get right
by any means but i know the goal is to
try and save my best for
those i value the most which is the
closest relationship to you with your
wife and and with your kids you know
make them save the best for them
rather than kind of be tired and grumpy
with them and then go out and then be on
form you know it's trying to shift it
the other way and it's counter culture
but
it's always going to make you happy you
know if and that's why
i say if you all know what someone's
like ask their wife because don't don't
look at the press reports and don't
read their own stories about themselves
you know ask person who really knows
them when the when the mask is off and
when it's you know the cameras aren't
really they're they're the ones and it's
not say
you know anyone's perfect but but try
and save your best for them and
i think
if you do ask my wife what
i would love her to say
i'd love her to say that i was loyal and
kind and fought for them
you know that's that's what i just i've
always tried to do in my life and
prioritize them and many times in in my
life in the early days of tv especially
there was so much pressure to
you know be away too much and go and do
that and do the extra episode and do the
extra thing and the you know discovery
channel are asking for one more thing
then you end up
burning burning the things are most
valuable because you're way too much you
you're focusing on this and it always
creates damage
and i'd say sorry for those times it was
way too much and and and that's why i
fought so hard to start to produce and
make our own shows where we owned the
format and we could decide it's not i go
no it's our boys half term i'm i'm not
gonna even though it's
you know tom cruise or whoever i'm we're
i'm gonna be at the half term for this i
wanna
a shift onto the family
and it's been a great thing it's been a
key thing
and the other stuff is work it'll always
be that you know it'll be there and it's
okay sometimes i fall into the trap of
doing that so you know you get an offer
come in and it's oh 50 grand or 100
grand to do this thing here it'll take
one day but i'd schedule to be in
indonesia that day with my partner and
i'm looking i'm going can i really turn
down a hundred grand
for one day just like hanging out on the
sofa with my partner it's a new
challenge that i've been contending with
what i mean you've been through this
well i think i think the answer is at
the same time you're hustling and you've
got to work and you've got to build it
and you're building it especially when
you get married and have kids you're
building for their future and all of us
have this struggle but i think listening
to that inner voice you know a little
bit and there's this line isn't there
that we walk where
you know this side is family this side
is work and the problem is if you only
try and walk this line everyone's always
asking favors you know it's just one off
it's one event there's one thing well
before you know it you're spending too
long on this side of the line and you're
creating damage and loss it's only
damaged so it's losing you're creating
loss on this side and i think what i've
learned is just shift the line a little
bit you know make the line here oh so
make it even more family orientated
yeah so so
when you drift over the line a few times
which you're gonna do you're still in
surplus you're still a surplus and and i
think the wisdom and experience of life
is knowing do you know what no we should
go and do that i will go and do that
event that's important
but
knowing also the ones that really
protect it's often the little things
isn't it like a
you know like the linesman story you
know like that school play or that
anniversary or whatever and listen i'm
speaking from a place of flawed
failure through many many times but i've
learned through those things why did you
say that because i got it wrong many
times
yeah just been there and made mistakes
and got them wrong but i've learned
through those
is that it's worth protecting the most
the thing of most value in your life and
i think then with success what happens
you reach a point where
you don't need that extra 100 grand
you know maybe when you're getting it
maybe you've got to hustle a bit maybe
you've got to make some sacrifices you
do to be successful you have to
sacrifice maybe you know and i was the
same i had to in those early days you
gotta you gotta go that extra mile i'm
not saying you don't you do
but maybe you reach point where enough's
enough and then
then what you're really saying to your
girlfriend or it might be your wife or
your kids at that stage is that i value
you more than a hundred grand and when
you're like successful you know it
doesn't get any easier to say no it
becomes more important
to say no
amen i felt that speaking of work
really compelled by um
when i read that you're the chief scout
i was like that's the ceo of the scouts
right
is that not the ceo of the scouts
effectively well i don't think i've ever
i've never had an aspiration to be like
a ceo ceo has always felt very important
even though we are on the diary of a ceo
i never feel like i see um
[Music]
greatest honor in my life has been to
you know be a be a small cog in this
incredible worldwide machine of 55
million young people whoa bound together
by a common set of values of respect and
kindness and humility and and adventure
and determination and life skills and
you know it's an amazing privilege i
never take it for granted it's a
worldwide force for good it truly is the
scout movement is unlike anything else
out there and
it really has been the greatest honour
of my life and
and i love it i can sum up my job as
chief scout three words you know
encourage encourage encourage you know
and shine the light on those the the
young people because the stuff that they
got get up to the missions they're on
the the efforts the endeavors the expert
what they do is amazing they're leading
the thing on climate change they're
leading in many refugee camps and
disaster areas helping serving and when
you get 57 million young people around
the world saying i make a promise to be
kind and helpful
you know
it's amazing there's a power to that and
it's brilliant
do you think your
your career is complete
and um i hope not i hope not i'm still
hustling i'm still i like that i like
the struggle i like the fight i like the
ambition we've built a brilliant team
we're pushing many endeavors you know
away from just the tv shows you know i'm
super proud of our be military fit our
veterans fitness business you know we
have our theme parks our adventure parks
at the nec and we're opening up new ones
around the world we have the scout staff
we you know we have education
initiatives i love it for me it's about
using this god-given platform we've been
given through the tv shows to try and do
exactly the same as we do with the tv
shows which is to shine a light on you
and say look what you can do will it
ever be complete and and i hope not i
think um
it's like my bucket list gets longer and
longer as i live in life yeah it's not
it's like the more things we could we
could do that and we could help do this
and
and i always want to live with that eyes
wide open
you know willing to be all in willing to
fail willing to pick myself up with
great people have that focused mission
of trying to empower other people
helping other people to find their
adventures in life whether it's through
books or tv shows or whatever to like be
able to go that extra mile to be able to
dig deep to understand the storms of
life come but sometimes you got to be
dogged and determined to keep going i
want to bring that adventure spirit to
people
every day i live on this earth that's
the goal to no end do you know and i
think i mean maybe i'll finish the tv
shows one day you know that that will
naturally
end in due course i can't i mean to be
honest i never thought i'd still be
doing it now you know but with we're
doing more tv shows than ever before
we're doing a new network show on ustv
next month we're starting season eight
of running while we're you know still
out there gunning it and going and i
love that but the tv shows will end
but the adventures won't you know i i
god willing you know i hope when um old
guy i'm gonna be having loads of
adventures with my kids and eventually
with grandkids and sharing that
adventure spirit because as you know you
know adventurous is truly a state of
mind whatever you're doing whatever you
know my wife always jokes that i'm gonna
be in the old people's home go come on
come on we're gonna do it we're gonna go
over you know and i think that's a state
of mind that is about pushing the
boundaries and
you know
having that resilience and and that kind
of wide-eyed gratitude for for life and
the connections and because the truth is
the world is amazing and it's a huge
privilege you look at everything that's
happening around the world there's
hardship and struggling in battle and
and loss and the fact that we get to
you know have our families and have
something we love to do and and that
we're safe and we we live in this kind
of a society that has a rule of law and
all these things are so easy to take for
granted we must never take that for
granted we've got to live with that eyes
wide open thank you and and keep that
adventurous state of mind firing bright
that far inside shining bright
never give up the the name of your
recent book um this book i got the sense
that it was slightly more special than
previous books to you and that it had
taken five years
to write this book
that you wrote it all yourself
it is it took a long time you know i was
reluctant to write it i wrote an
autobiography called mud sweat and tears
originally
but uh the truth is you know that and
that would do well you know it did 20
weeks at number one and i always kind of
felt that i'm i'm not going to beat that
you know i'm not going to do another but
we're done
but that book really ended as tv started
and so many of the questions that i get
asked by by my kids and by people in the
street always like the behind the scenes
what was it like on this what was it
like taking that person or what about
the struggles there or whatever and in a
way they're the stories that i wanted my
boys to understand you know and i think
my kids are kind of growing up and
seeing the good side seeing the the
things that have worked but aren't
always aware of the many failures behind
behind those successes
and i wanted to be able to share all of
that and share the things that actually
made the difference and i wanted to
write it myself and
you know be honest in it and so it took
a long time to write but i'm i'm really
proud of it and i think it
it was always going to be cool never
give up you know it's at a time where i
think the world's coming through an
incredibly
continuous to be an incredibly tough
time and i think that
spirit of relentless determination is
needed more than ever with all people
and young people especially
so i'm proud of the stories and and uh
proud to call it never give up when i
wrote my book i i didn't realize this
until i wrote it that it was actually
much more a learning process than it was
a preaching process
you because it is a journey writing a
book is there something that you learned
that you didn't know before you started
on that journey of writing never give up
that
who was profound or a problem you solved
from putting pen to paper that you that
you hadn't solved before that comes to
mind well i've definitely learned of for
writing or speaking to be good
it has to be difficult
it has to be painful you know how often
do we see the person who stands up and
stands on stage and gives a talk and
loves the sound of their own voice and
it's just like it's a ball
they're a ball
you know but the person who's
this is hard to articulate or talk about
but for what it's worth this is where
you know you're there
and it's the same with writing i think
it's got to be vulnerable and it's got a
have that struggle to it
and that's why it took me a while
what did you find what did you feel
well yeah for me there was a couple of
questions that when i started a chapter
i hadn't actually answered them yet and
by the end of the chapter i'd answered
the question but it was because of that
process is it easy for you to be
vulnerable are you somewhat because we
only think of someone that's been in the
sas and this you know again talking
about the public stereotype here tough
guy resilience
vulnerability seems to be the antithesis
of that for a lot of people the complete
opposite
how have you been you know we talk about
toxic masculinity a lot now i sat here
with terry crews the actor big tough guy
and his new book tough which is about
toxic masculinity what's your
relationship with vulnerability
were first of all terry crews hero
and one of our running wild guests
actually i took him on one last year and
he was like with you very honest about
some of this stuff
vulnerability
was hard initially but i think it's
it's where life is you know and like
with
like when you climb any big mountain you
know where your rope to someone 24 hours
a day it brings you close
but it also is where the bonds are you
know and when you
when you're vulnerable with someone it
creates a connection you know you and me
probably feel more connected by being
the vulnerability than the look at this
you know vulnerability creates bonds and
creates strength
but like all these things there's a pain
and a it takes a strength to do it
but i think um i'm not scared to show
that you know i've got nothing to prove
and i don't want people to think it's
just all heroic you know i want people
know that the
that it's just
there's been many struggles through it
all but these things have quietly helped
me and i always think people have two
phases of their life
one is like
you don't want the world to see who you
really are you're out there you project
this kind of image
and then the second half is you no
longer care you just want to be honest
and when it honest there's there's an
amazing bonds with the really people you
want to create bonds with and some
people have that realization at 25 and
they live the rest of life in this
empowered way some people don't reach
that point until they're 85 they live
the whole life with this mask and it's
only when they're
with that maybe nurse and a nurse in the
first person they're actually being
honest and vulnerable and broken with
but you eventually realize it you know
and
the goal i suppose of life is to get
this place early because it's where the
wealth is it's where the it's where the
happiness is because you're not going to
pretend any longer
and you can form those deeper
relationships as you said which is
exactly what happens when we have these
conversations there you go
we have a closing tradition on the
podcast which is our last guest asks a
question for the next guest
so the question is if you had to predict
where will you be
this time
in five years time
wow the truth is i hope to
hope to be
doing the same sort of thing in the
sense that living this mission of trying
to empower other people to find their
adventures through all these different
means you know through the tv shows or
the books or whatever you know i i love
that mission you know it starts with my
relationship with my kids and it extends
to scouts and it extends beyond that
from there so i hope to have that same
mission maybe at a slightly slower pace
you know we film a lot of shows at the
moment and it it's a way a lot and it's
you know it's it's um
it definitely has full-on elements to it
so maybe kind of dial down the pace a
bit but but
um same mission and and still protecting
family first you know beyond before work
before before even that mission protect
family first and and keep that those
relationships strong
you know my body aches every day i got
many scars
like an old man getting up in the
morning
but uh i don't apologize for any of
those things and i think by the end of
my life if i can uh i don't want to
arrive in a perfectly preserved body so
i quote i want to come skidding in
sideways covered in scars screaming yo
what a ride you know and that long may
that spirit continue yeah thank you so
much for the time and generosity i've
got to say this does really feel like a
huge honor for me because of how
infrequently you do anything like this
so i i just want to communicate how much
of an honor this genuinely feels like
for me and i feel very special and i
feel like our team are very i'm honored
to have you here and to have this
conversation with you you're someone
that's achieved an unbelievable amount
and for you to be so honest and because
it would be so easy for you to say to
play into the narrative that you have
super powers but it's almost impossible
to get you to indulge in that and as you
say that makes the things you've
achieved so attainable for everybody
that's listening including myself and if
it is something that i can learn and
grow in a muscle i can build then that
for me is incredibly empowering and
empowerment
is so evidently at the center of all the
work you do with the scouts with your
new book never give up which i highly
recommend everybody reads the paperback
is out on the 9th of june but it's
really you can tell you've written it
you can tell that it's come from a place
of real authenticity and someone who is
is willing to tell you the truth and we
need a lot more of that so
thank you i'll never be able to say
thank you enough for coming and doing
this and uh yeah thanks for the
inspiration over the years you've made
you've empowered me just in this
conversation yeah it's like um well
likewise you're doing an amazing job and
thank you your dad he will definitely
know it i'm gonna i'm gonna text him i'm
gonna send him a voice now after this so
thank you thanks thank you
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast my girlfriend
came upstairs yesterday when i was
having a shower and she said to me that
she tried the heel protein shake which
lives on my fridge over there and she
said it's amazing low calories you get
your 20 odd grams of protein you get
your 26 vitamins and minerals and it's
nutritionally complete in the protein
space there's lots of things but it's
hard to find something that is nice
especially when consumed just with water
and that is nutritionally complete the
salted caramel one if you put some ice
cubes in it and you put it in a blender
and you try it is as good as pretty much
any milkshake on the market just mixed
with water it's been a game changer for
me because i'm trying to drop my calorie
intake and i'm trying to be a little bit
more healthy with my diet so this is
where heel fits in my life thank you
hill for making a product that i
actually like
[Music]
[Music]
you